hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba what's
your name good sir Marc Ricci aka movie
man Marc movie man Marc who I have kind
of known for years three years and now
he's living down in California and I
said get your ass over here you only
live an hour away now yeah come on over
movie man Marc he could check out his
YouTube channel has a whole bunch of
variety of comedy he looks like Tom
Cruise so good-looking and funny what
more can you ask and he was just showing
me this other channel that he helps out
with oh good we're gonna explain the
suit yeah let's play the suit because
we're gonna do honest shows Avengers
infinity war really if we just never
explained yeah this is where every video
six side studios is this other channel
where they do fan films of spider-man
and they even put up one just a few
months ago that got like a hundred 30k
views and it's like an over an hour long
yeah the biggest one has 7.4 million but
we don't know why it does but maybe
maybe a confident he's dressed as
spider-man today because we're gonna do
reaction for honest trailers Avengers
infinity Wars this is from screen
junkies and by the way I was on a movie
5 last week so go check that episode out
movie man mark are you excited I'm super
set this is 6 minutes long yeah a new
record for them
no no yeah shows that I don't watch them
too much but I mean I love honest
trailers though
hey and I'm being honest be likable
alright you did it
the following trailer is read it as
Charlie Matt Bailey yet no saw the Meg
with him today's episode is brought to
you the mess or me yeah exact people to
sponsor
from the Thanos of Hollywood comes what
could be the best movie marbles ever
made but without a doubt is the most
movie marbles ever made yeah there is
just so much movie in this movie look at
all that movie the MCU were after 10
years of having to streamline their plot
so normies would know what's happening
bajo starting so big they'll draw me
right into episode 19 part 1 of 2
without wasting a second on who anyone
is or why you should care because let's
face it you're either on this hype train
by now or the Winter Soldier using
Rocket Raccoon as a sidearm horn means
do you sidewards rebellion against their
destructive programming did weren't you
listening to me are you yawning all your
favourite heroes are here like Tony
Stark the scientist who finds that magic
exists and takes it in stride wizard but
literally can't even win another quit
the guy with a goatee shows up what is
your job Zach who decides making balloon
animals star the Lord whose entire first
movie was completely undone we'd like to
express our profound gratitude for your
help and savings and the decimated sound
another bond here shows up she's trying
to copy Captain America who heroically
accepts his reduced role as guy who
knows a guy can we do that not me not
here I know someone who could yeah yeah
published Yves rocher's
Haider whose lack of screen time proves
no one knew how big of a deal he be yeah
and spider-man
the boy who'd rather hitch a ride into
space and die than stay home and be in
venom you me both yes but they're not
alone because all these other characters
are also back like Bruce Banner a man in
desperate need of a phase-three recap
video Tony you've lost another super
Bock with Scott Emma doesn't have like a
band like like the Beatles Scarlet Witch
the x-man who's completed her Halle
Berry arc of losing her weird accent as
the movies go no explanation gamora
Center the whole story and the best
actor didn't see that one coming
Loki and slightly more dead than the
last two times the rest of the guardians
pre James Gunn petition a few weeks ago
and Bucky the one on dart is no goat
cheese farmer but they're not alone
either
because holy crap there are so so many
people in this movie like roadies like
recapping all the characters well good
wow that's a you know there's a lot of
care Baku Red Skull Nick Fury hey where
you been
Thunderbolt Ross again okay Marissa Hall
right name name shows Kevin Feige Alex
so next time our nest next time any
ready
or not for all the characters crammed in
there same thrill as it centers around a
buff bald guy trying to grow his rock
collection color twice and every POW in
age of Ultron to do it himself waited
like seven whole movement including two
that didn't waste in space and then
boldly said you sir are a really bad
stepfather dang what a great comic his
loins and traditions briefly killing
people off to Goose sales where with a
single snap of the fingers Disney erase
the box of the potential of Black
Panther spider-man five seventh of the
Guardians Doctor Strange and if you
think these debts are gonna stick I got
a copy of The Death of Superman to sell
I mean it's still in the original bag in
condition with the armband to come on
no one how about the death of Tony Stark
they say all anything American about
Thor okay how about a copy of infinity
Gulliver the same thing happens and
they'll come back just fine yep cool I
never read that was so cool I read a
story there's a moon honestly for
Stooges beards of no nation he was a one
eyed blonde Thor flying Purple People
beater under armour Dumbo to wall thanks
for nothing beside the Avengers shorty
of a forge a hologram for the king Teen
Titans grow it wasn't me it was the one
on stand do dodo dodo dodo
tomorrow Red Dead Redemption
and the Justice League game of stones so
what's gonna give him a password
pretending this was a standalone movie
yeah yeah we are today's episode ok
brought to you by the US Army find out
more by clicking the link below we have
to do work to find out dying yeah early
when it's free look we're tiny don't
think we're gonna tell you we're all a
little Moody's the ER venom I should
have taken me into the histogram for the
comment section yeah that a person Asian
yeah he does do impressions John Bailey
right yes John Bailey does do
impressions John Bailey good that was
good it was good
I kind of expected him to break down a
little bit more of the plot a little bit
more of a movie he kind of just like a
giant recap of the characters more so of
the characters than the story they
didn't talk about a moment that I was
thinking about earlier today infinity
we're still a movie I'll think about
when Tony Stark is stabbed by Thanos see
every time I watch that movie in the
theaters the crowd gasp yeah and then
first time I watch it before watching
the movie I was thinking if they kill
Iron Man that'd be awesome die be brave
that be bold but I remember when I
watched that and I think everyone in the
crowd feels the same way when he gets
stabbed as an audience member who wants
Marvel to be bold and take risky choices
you're like killing our man will be the
right step but they're gonna get stabbed
you're like no dude I don't want you to
die yeah just the first time you see
infinity war you're kind of thinking
anything can happen so your mouth is
open the whole time even the opening
sequence yeah three deaths yeah in a
matter of ten minutes I was a little
scared for Hulk - I know I should have
been I was overreacting but when Hulk's
getting his ass kicked
yeah you're like his Hulk like anything
is possible but I mean anyone who didn't
die will die in Avengers force
easily yeah yeah things are so
predictable now I've been America will
have the big heroic death but as I was
hearing it I was thinking how would you
do exactly an honest trailers of
infinity war I just kind of expecting
them to break down a little bit more
like plot points and everything but
you're dealing with so many characters
and you do have to cover that and the
honest shows usually do cover that as
well yeah I think a lot of it could have
been guessed though like if they made an
honest trailer for this movie before the
movie even came out how different would
it be they didn't wait on the plot yeah
mostly the characters and the idea that
there's so many of them fitting into one
movie for once they put out a couple
things that I never thought about with
star-lord and Xander how in guardians
the galaxy won his whole arc of being a
hero for Sandor and then this one season
don't get destroyed it's like you know
you have different directors coming on
to make continuations of previous movies
and not all of them all not all the plot
points get old importance going forward
even kind of like with the situation
with Thanos to begin with I mean Thanos
has changed his appearance and look and
he did say an age of Ultron that's I'll
be back he doesn't say I'll be back cool
weird color for their skin and Austrian
accents they've kind of been like we
want Danis for infinity war we don't
really know exactly what we're gonna die
think that was my probably my favorite
part just the fact that they've been
building up Thanos for so long in the
post-credits scene age of Ultron was
like I'm gonna do this myself and then
where's Thanos at and then finally it's
like he's got minions doing his work for
him I've definitely pointed that in the
review about black panther though - of
how you see black panther in this movie
he's kind of just a glorified cameo well
Conda feels like I can say and it's like
oh cool they're here but you know they
don't they don't really get screen time
that's well justified it's kind of feel
that way with cap a lot more with Black
Panther they really just did not realize
how much of a box office success black
Paul would have been you know it's funny
that some people actually thought that
those deaths would be permanent they are
mark I mean they are movie man mark I
cried in the theater I was so sad to see
them all go so soon and they say
something - in any Infinity Gauntlet
comic book cuz I read the gauntlet comic
book and that is true like they reverse
all the deaths from the snap
they are gonna sway a little bit from
the comic I feel just because of the
whole time travel yeah and the quantum
realm whatever they're doing with
ant-man well I think some people will
have permanent deaths with the next
Avengers when I watched the the fading
away because I had just read the comic
like I read
finding on the comic like a couple weeks
before I watched the movie it was the
rare moment in a movie theater where I
had when I was watching it going oh yeah
well that's what happens in the comic I
wasn't with the crowd like yeah but I'm
on the same page as you but it wasn't
because I read the comic it was just
because you know movies yeah I mean
there's that and also the comic like
yeah it's just what I was in the comic
that makes sense but in terms of if
you're not as familiar with it it's a
really damn I think if Black Panther and
spider-man survived and everyone else
died I think there would maybe be a
chance that you know people would
believe like this is permanent you know
the guardians to like they're not gonna
only make two guardians movies I mean
maybe right now they are because of the
whole James oh yeah but you know in the
moment it's like once Black Panther and
spider-man went away you're like okay
there came back good more would be the
only one I would buy but they've already
pretty much confirmed that she's in the
soulstone which I'm surprised I didn't
touch on here either maybe because it's
kind of hard to predict what's gonna
happen next
yeah I hope she doesn't come back but I
just feel like she will think the Russos
did confirm she's in the soulstone yeah
but you know I Kevin Feige again has
said like oh these deaths that are
coming up are gonna be permanent and if
you bring back every one that faded away
and Gamora who does that leave to be
permanent yeah there's even rumors that
Loki's gonna come back like no no Thanos
said no you're dead for good this time
something along those lines I think if
you bring back everyone who faded sure
but I'm like keep Loki and Gamora dead
please keep Gamora dead it was like the
biggest moment she's always saw donnas
got Star Trek she's got avatar she's got
other sci-fi films but I know people
like Gamora so I wouldn't be surprised
why are you hitting on women I'm hitting
on you come on this channel and you hate
on women look man I got a voice my
opinion it's a free speech on YouTube
you don't have to yes and still good
honest trailer and I would not know how
to do an honest shot for a movie this
epic six minutes is really short for a
40-hour job at the same time you know
trailers or two and a half minutes so
it's like they found a good they found a
good balance
yes they did yeah balance Oh exactly
exactly
did it but no I was thinking a balance
act as in spider-man balance act the
film that I made on sick side studios
with 7.4 stop but I mean the fan whose
balance stick with a lots of bars say
this with women you gotta cut it out
keep bringing up the women thing guys
I'm completely respectful for women I
feel like I have to tell them that you
know you should have yes and you guys
can subscribe to reject nation yeah
click that notification about can
subscribe button suck check out a movie
man mark on the movie man mark YouTube
channel seriously he deserves more
subscribers and check out his make out
videos she's done with women there's
like three videos guys make it out with
chicks yeah I mean the idea was to get
people to click and it seemed like it
worked for you those are the only videos
I watch those videos are gonna go final
i'ma go check them out